19 continues to be an issue for the nfl
the enhanced protocols are kicked in as
of tomorrow for every team across the
board
i feel like this is just
that
last ditch effort to avoid
outbreaks
to avoid losing games
and to avoid the eventual necessity of
putting everyone in a hotel which for
whatever reason the league is avoiding
the union is avoiding no one wants to do
it i understand it's a hardship but
the bigger hardship is losing game
checks that will never come back and i
feel like that almost has to happen
before everyone realizes we should just
check into a hotel for the rest of the
season
yeah i mean mike if if you look at the
numbers the nfl came out with this week
putting pen to paper
here's what you figure
that in the first three months
of this uh epidemic and of testing
august september and october the nfl had
162 positive tests
between
close contact employees and players okay
coaches equipment people all that
okay 162.
and in the last two weeks they've had
108
and as you look at
every day you know the los angeles rams
have a positive and by the way the rams
the first positive
since uh the opening day of training
camp when a rookie uh i think it was
terrell lewis reported uh kovitt
positive but they had not had a positive
until tuesday of this week but you see
it every day it trickles in trickles in
trickles in so to me
i think what we're going to see when
next week's numbers are when this week's
numbers are reported next week
you're going to see almost exactly
across the board the exact same number
of players and key team officials being
positive as they were in the first three
months
so to me
i i think it is a matter of time mike
and
i'm not trying to be a harbinger of doom
but i do think that it's illogical to
expect that what is happening all over
the country will not happen on at least
one team
well and i think we're being realistic
we've been realistic from the get-go
it's the people who refuse to
acknowledge that this is a serious
problem even as the
death toll crosses 250 000 with no signs
of stopping on the way to 300 400 and
beyond
when you continue to send the players
out into the community
every day after practice and the numbers
in the community are out of control
you make it impossible to implement the
nfl's basic plan the basic plan
simple
we catch a guy who's positive in our
testing net we draw a line around him
and anyone who is in close contact gets
removed from the facility during the
incubation period that's how they're
dealing with one of the biggest doughnut
holes in this pandemic the delay between
exposure and developing systems and
symptoms and shedding virus that's fine
as long as you only got one guy who's
walking through the door positive what's
gonna happen here maybe by the middle of
december if not sooner you're gonna have
two guys three guys
four guys
five guys all coming through positive at
the same time
then you have to remove them and anyone
with whom they were in close contact and
before you know it you're not gonna have
enough guys to field a team that's where
i think this is heading that's why the
cdc and the cdc isn't doing it for the
nfl but i'm saying this is what the
numbers are going up the cdc all of a
sudden is urging people not to travel
for thanksgiving they see what's coming
if we have all these little mini super
spreader events in living rooms and
dining rooms throughout the country
next week
and everyone then goes back to their
lives and keeps spreading it and
spreading it and spreading it that's
when you're going to get to the point
peter where you don't have one guy at
any given time who's positive on a team
you've got five or more
mike the challenge is uh a very
prominent
club official told me over the weekend
last weekend was
you know the idea is to keep the one
positive test to one
once it gets in your or in your building
in your organization and it becomes five
or ten
that's when that team is in real trouble
and i think the one other thing to
realize about
what the nfl has shown that it will do
the nfl will force teams to play
even if it means that they're at a
distinct advantage do you remember
before the season mike when we said ah
you know what if the minnesota vikings
have four offensive linemen out with
covid they're not going to force the
vikings to play the bears this weekend
because
you know too dangerous for the
quarterback doesn't give him enough
chance
the nfl has changed its mind
the nfl thinks now that if you have
enough warm bodies to play in this game
you're going to play in this game and so
that's why to me is one
one gm we were talking about this the
other day he said
the practice squad has never been more
important and i've never spent more time
on the practice squad than i have this
year
those 16 people
any of whom are gonna be called upon at
any time to have to save your bacon
peter the pivot point i believe came at
that raiders buccaneers game that was
supposed to be on sunday night football
it was flexed back to four eastern in
the event it had to be moved or
postponed
that was when i think the league decided
you know what it doesn't matter if you
didn't have an offensive line in the
building all week it doesn't matter we
don't care you have to play the game
because let's just get the games played
let's not delay it to monday or tuesday
night i know john gruden was livid that
it wasn't delayed i was like hey we've
had these monday and tuesday night games
i'd love to see
tampa bay
and the raiders on a monday or tuesday
night no balls on the t we're going to
kick it we're going to get the games in
and we're going to move on and just keep
going through the season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports